elisabeth guigou le ministre de la
justice a annoncé la création d'un
contrat d'union sociale il s'agit de
donner un cadre juridique aux couples
homosexuels notamment ces couples qui
n'ont pas accès au mariage c'était l'un
des engagements de la campagne
électorale valérie fournier jean paul
chaussée non il est sa vie de couple va
changer juridiquement le contrat l'union
sociale va reconnaître l'existence
légale de tous les couples homosexuels
un contrat qui mettra fin à des
situations souvent douloureuse en cas de
décès on n'assistera plus enfin à des
situations familiales conflictuelles ou
le partenaire et et pouvait se retrouver
ce pôle il est totalement par la film de
l'autre le nouveau gouvernement a donc
tenu sa promesse électorale
l'union hors mariage de deux personnes
aura maintenant à 7 juridique mais les
associations homosexuelles compte bien
être vigilante car le contrat d'union
social n'inclut pas le cas les couples
binationaux ni celui des fonctionnaires
en cas de mutation d'un des deux
partenaires
et puis surtout ce contrat n'est pas un
mariage si on se base sur un principe
d'égalité des droits
demain on réclamera le droit au mariage
par exemple où le droit à l'adoption
le droit la stimulation artificielle les
femmes célibataires particulier de
lesbiennes et cetera et cetera un peu à
l'image de ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays européens
avec ce contrat d'union sociale la
france ne suit pas encore les exemples
américains et surtout scandinaves où les
mariages homosexuels sont autorisés mais
elle reconnaît aujourd'hui leur alliance
de coeur
[Musique]